I was really looking forward to coming
here and meeting great people at my
first strange Loop and maybe hiring some
of them and then I got a message from
Alex saying hey another speaker has
gotten co could you give a
talk so I wrote this talk
yesterday it is based on a bunch of
research done by myself and my
colleagues in anthropic as well as some
external collaborators uh and please all
the mistakes are
mine so anthropic is a public benefit
Corporation founded about 2 years ago to
try to make this whole AI thing go well
we do a bunch of research but the lens I
wanted to take for a strange Loop
conference was the lens of strange Loops
themselves this is a concept or term
kind of popularized by Douglas hofstader
in godal eer back in his later book I am
a strange Loop the idea being that you
have these kind of interesting feedback
loops or cycles that cross layers of
abstraction that kind of are unclear
where they start or end and often end up
in some sense back where they started
and in other senses kind of
different and so I want to use the idea
of a strange loop as a lens to explore
language
models and it's interesting to me
because a few months ago Hofer gave an
interview where he said when will we
feel that models deserve to be thought
of as fully or perhaps partly fledged
eyes like when when would an AI system
have some kind of selfhood and I'm not
going to answer that question
today and he said in the case of
advanced models like GT4 or I like to
think Claude anthropics model it feels
like there is something
there and I also want to acknowledge
that H finds this kind of deeply
distressing that humans might be
eclipsed by computer systems and lose
something that makes us special and
unique I want to acknowledge that but
then Focus the talk on the positive side
that I see some really fascinating
insights and a lot of Beauty in these
models and I think I've learned a lot
about Computing and thought by working
with them and studying
them and so I want to kind of explore
what we've learned about language models
recently from two perspectives one the
kind of inside out perspective starting
at the lower level Primitives and
understanding how they combine and give
rise to this representation and
complexity and composition and then in
the second half of the talk from the
outside in what are the behavioral
things that we see emerging what are the
feedback loops that we use to train
these models and some interesting
findings there my goal is to leave you
with more questions than answers be
warned
and so the first thing to say is that I
do see a lot of real Elegance in machine
learning but it's Elegance like that of
biology rather than that of engineering
or physics or
mathematics we see self-similar systems
we see abstractions across scales we see
different Dynamics at the small and
large scales at times and analogies all
over the place and just as evolution is
this sort of long computationally
intensive process that produces that
complexity rather than a deliberate
design in machine learning you know in
in nature we see things like peacock
feathers the iridescence is from
nanoscale structures that physically
interact with light waves we see eyes
that can perceive these light waves and
in machine learning the analogy of
evolution is gradient descent this in
some sense a computationally more
powerful method and it can create
mindboggling structure and
behaviors as an example we can use image
classification techniques or image
recognition techniques and start to map
out what is it that they see along
different mechanistic
dimensions but the challenge is to find
and understand those internal
representations because they're quite
complex and so I want to start by
walking you through simple convolutional
image recognition networks just one case
that one of my some of my colleagues had
reverse engineered so a convolutional
network is sort of the classic neural
network each neuron is just a function
which sets all negative numbers to zero
and passes positive numbers on unchanged
and the connections between them are
just a learned multiplier multiplier
sort of ranges between 1 and z or minus
one and you just multiply the value of
each n neuron by its connection to the
subsequent neuron and add up all those
and pass them on so this is a simple
feed forward Network where each layer
will compute some function of its input
and pass it to the next one and the
convolution is that you start by putting
in all the pixel pixels of an image and
then at each layer it gets smaller and
smaller okay of summarizing that
information and so the basic units of
our analysis for these networks are
going to be what we call features and a
feature is something like an
interpretable semantic thing it's kind
of hard to Define what a semantic thing
is so I'll just call it a feature and
let you work it out and we find that
many neurons in these networks actually
correspond to interpret all things such
as the neuron that's visualized there is
one which detects cars the output of
that neuron will be relatively large
when there's a car in the picture and
relatively low otherwise we have weights
weights are kind of the analogy of the
binary instructions if the neural
network is like the machine architecture
or the instruction set the weights
themselves are the actual program and
then the circuits are how these are
connected you might think of them as the
structure of function call so the
control flow
graph and I mentioned before that many
of these neurons respond to
interpretable Concepts and the car was
one example but these ones are curve
detectors these appear earlier in the
model closer to the raw pixels and when
you visualize them you can clearly see
that there are curves here you know you
can imagine how you might put these
together to form a
circle and the interesting thing is that
these curve detectors or the
identification of these neurons as curve
detectors because the network doesn't
come with semantic labels right it's
just neuron 3B column
379 right it doesn't say curve detector
for the top left corner
but when we visualize these we get
pretty robust things when we go look at
the examples in the training data set
which activate these neurons we find a
lot of pictures of Curves with about
that geometry when we hand draw examples
synthetic examples or we optimize to
find best one they trigger on those two
works for joint tuning feature
implementation means we can actually
replace subparts of the network with a
handwritten program that uses old school
computer vision techniques to detect
curves and find that the overall
performance of the network is maintained
by doing this if we substitute a program
that does something else of course it's
not we can tell that the features are
used right that they were actually were
active when they were doing
this that's features if we look at
weights the weight pattern here is the
for the inputs to this
neuron how sort of strongly do we
upweight or downweight the result based
on those the location in the image is
what we're showing here and what we see
here is that this neuron appears to be
active if a thing is on the right hand
side of the image and inactive or
unexcited if it's on the
left like does anyone know what this
means no you couldn't see my slides
before could you you need the context to
work out what this means the input here
is a neuron which is active for a dog
head facing to the r this is a pretty
specific concept but the neural network
has a lot of neurons in this
architecture and and combined with these
weights we get a neuron which detects
rightwood facing dogs not just the dog
head but actually attached to a
body and we can see the analogist neuron
if we look elsewhere for facing left and
so we now have a dog facing right
detector and a dog facing left detector
this doesn't seem to me like an entirely
natural categorization right in some
sense dogs facing left and dogs facing
right are basically the same object but
this neural network knows nothing about
dogs only things about pixels and the
regularities in patterns of pixels that
it's been trained
on and so it learns that a dog is simply
the composition of dogs facing left dogs
facing right and dogs facing
forth which is pretty
cool if you want to detect a car it
turns out that car detector is built out
of a detector for windows at the top of
the image for wheels at the bottom of
the image and for the body of a car kind
of anywhere in the
image and the interesting thing here is
that this means that this network is not
Rota and variant right if you rotate the
image 90° or 180° this car detector will
no longer detect cars because while
we've labeled it a car detector what it
really is in some sense is a detector of
the things that we have labeled cars in
the training data set if we wanted it to
be rotation invariant we'd have to do
some different training procedure where
we flipped over some images and kept the
same label and so you can see that as a
failure or a bias of the network or you
can see it as a way to pick up some
additional statistic statistical
regularity in the world that people tend
to take pictures of cars the right way
up usually instead of cars upside down
or holding their camera upside
down and so you can do these
compositions you can look at curves you
can compose your curves into a detector
for things surrounded by some other
context you can get a circle detector
out of
this you can get horizontal and vertical
this
and so far I've been talking about the
easy cases where these semantic features
just do cleanly decompose into lower
level features and we can tell what's
going on and each neuron kind of has a
clear meaning when humans look at
it but unfortunately not all neurons are
nicely semantically well behaved with a
single
meaning so this neuron uh 4
E55 is activated by cat
faces the fronts of cars and the legs of
cats and you might think to yourself wow
you know this AI thing is getting pretty
good what do these things have in common
I didn't realize that they were the same
thing in some
sense and our best guess is that
actually the thing that they have in
common is that they don't have anything
in
common that these are three things that
in the training data set almost never
co-occur in the same part of an image
right a cat leg and a cat face is going
to be a different area and apparently
imet just doesn't have many cat faces
superimposed on cars like opportunity
for the internet people
but but this makes interpretability much
more challenging because we have to
understand how we unpick this and our
hypothesis is that the neural network is
actually using this to pack more
semantic features into fewer neurons and
then disambiguating them using other
information in other parts of the
network because for for example there
might be some context cues is this a
setting in which you would usually have
a car or a cat there's only one letter
difference but the images look a little
different and so our hypothesis is what
we call
superposition and in toy models tiny
little Transformer networks with a toy
size number of parameters we can kind of
see this emerging if we have five
different features that we might want to
represent and we give them slightly
different weightings in the loss so it's
more important to represent some
features than others in the natural
setting the hypothesis would say this
happens because some prates are more
common or more informative than others
uh and when all of the features are
always present to some degree it will
learn to represent just the two most
important features orthogonally so you
can retrieve them from those activations
without any error or
interference but once you get to a
setting where most features are not
present most of the time you know there
are like a thousand or thousand
categories in a million images in image
net and a relatively small fraction of
images have cars and a somewhat larger
fraction have
cats and so you can represent things
using just opposite direction pairs
right and so this means that if you have
for example one of the features say the
feature that's going up to the top left
and the one that's going to the top
right this is indistinguishable from
having neither that's also quite
unlikely and so most of the time on
average you come out ahead by using this
sparity and then if you get less common
still and features get rarer you might
start embedding them as a pentagon and
here we have some cosign similarity
between the features and so when one
feature is present it will look like
other features are also present to a
small degree and our hypothesis is that
the network probably works out how to
correct for that in another part later
on and when we investigate superposition
it's full of structure I'm not going to
go into this but but there's connections
to all kinds of things from compressed
sensing to sphere packing which comes up
in chemistry all the
time so who here has ever tried to
interpret a sequence of bits as meaning
something okay like could good 2/3 of
you who here just doesn't put up their
hand and
talks oh like 12 people okay thank you
thank
you and so here what we're trying to do
is just this toy problem we're trying to
represent shapes in a particular color
and we have three different shapes and
five different colors and so kind of the
obvious way to represent this in many of
the languages we know and love is we
represent colors and we represent shapes
and then the object we're looking for is
a color shape pair right so if we want
to represent a white circle we' say well
white means that we represent a and
circle means we represent F so AF means
a white circle on the other hand a red
square would be B so a fbh would be a
white circle and a red square right so
this gives us some amount of
representation of different objects
reasonably compactly and it certainly
makes sense to us
humans we could if we didn't mind
spending more bits just assign
everything a unique code and then we can
represent exactly different subsets the
disadvantage is that it's just more
expensive or we can go the other way and
say well we have 16 possibilities and we
have four bits like who here knows how
many possibilities you can represent
with four
bits and so here you know a white circle
is just a whereas a white square would
be AB d and a black Square would be AB C
D and if you got BC then that definitely
means something and it turns out to be
white
triangle but with one bit extra you can
give yourself much more structure and
this is something that neural networks
actually seem to do and so so here we've
used three bits to represent the
different colors that we might have and
two bits to represent the different
shapes so here if we want a white circle
we would have to say well the color
white means that we need a but not b or
c and the circle means that we want D
but not e so a d will give us a white
circle on this
diagram and we can kind of think of this
as representing a superposition if we
imagine that each of these bits is like
a question is the neuron active or
inactive neurons are of course
continuous rather than binary but for
Simplicity we can kind of visualize this
as a question of
representation and I I see something
interesting here in the distinction
between can you access individual parts
of this representation or isolate which
part of the representation corresponds
to a particular semantic concept or is
there a kind of larger implicit
structure where you have some kind of
lookup table nature and you have to
untangle
those
all of that has been about convolutional
neural networks which are really cool
and with a new hotness back in
2012 and AI has been moving pretty
quickly
lately uh so Alex net was more than 10
years ago which is so long in machine
learning at the moment and so
Transformers are the architecture of
choice for sequence modeling and
sequences usually in this case means
text words which is already an
incredibly rich source of semantic
structure and what do Transformers do
differently to Classic neural networks
well they have two important additional
features Beyond just the neurons that
pass things from layer to layer the
first thing is that Transformers have
what we call the residual Stream So a
classic neural network each layer of
neurons will process the entire input
and then pass their output to the next
layer in a Transformer we kind of have
these blocks off to the side they take
in the current state of the residual
stream modify it and then add their
output back to the residual stream so
it's possible for information to flow
straight through the entire network from
start to end and the other thing is what
we call attention heads this is kind of
the equivalent of the role of
convolutions where the neurons in a
convolutional network will take input
from many neurons in a kind of fixed
geometry that zooms the image out so to
speak in a Transformer model the
attention heads will query particular
information from earlier in the sequence
based on the current semantics I'm not
going to go into how they're implemented
it's pretty cool but that would make my
talk too long and I wrote this
yesterday and so the attention patterns
that we get from those queries kind of
become a a new primitive that we have to
understand just like the features and
weights and a simple in
network and so if we graph you know uh
the y- axis is which token index are we
looking from and the x-axis is what are
we looking to
we kind of have this interesting
structure right where in blue this is a
particular strength of attention we have
some particular
tokens and when we go look at that we
find what we call induction Heads This
is parts of the attention mechanism that
are performing a particular trick they
look for the previous time or many
previous occurrences of the current
token or word and then they look at what
happened
next and so texts will often have
sequences of words you know pairs of
words or a word with a suffix that
repeats several times and it turns out
that you can do better at predicting
what comes next if you recognize that if
a thing happened say you had a before
and you've just seen a b is considerably
more likely than it used to be if I say
99 bottles of beer on the wall and
you're an AI system you might not know
what's coming next but by the time I get
to 97 bottles of beer on the wall you
can probably be pretty sure what I'm
about to say and that's kind of the role
of these induction
heads the induction heads we actually
found through this lowlevel mechanistic
microscopic interpretability and then
confirmed that we could see effects at
the macro scale induction heads take two
layers to form right you you can't have
a one layer Transformer with induction
heads unless you modify the architecture
in which case you do get them and we
actually get this loss bump where the
induction heads form and work out how to
do this copying trick and we see that in
the scaling curves so this is over nine
orders of magnitude for different size
models we see a bump where the model
training curve behaves differently
exactly where induction heads form
exactly where we see the change in
loss but ultimately the thing I want to
pause on here is kind of philosophically
interesting this is an AI system which
has learned induction by being exposed
to a huge quantity of data and
generalizing logical rules for how it's
formed it has learned induction by
induction before it understood
induction if you want to read more of
this kind of mechanistic
interpretability work Transformers
circuits. Hub is a website that has
anthropics interpretability research as
well as comments and replications by
many of our amazing
collaborators that's the outside in the
inside out viw how do we start at the
bottom and kind of work our way up just
some of the highlights the other thing I
want to talk about is the outside in
view go well we have these loops and
abstractions right we start at the
bottom we get one view if we start at
the top looking down what kind of
emergent behaviors do we see what kind
of feedback loops do we put models
through or construct using models
themselves to train a large language
model is a complicated task but
basically it has two stages in the first
stage which I'm not going to cover today
we do what we call pre-training you take
some large Cor of text and you train the
model just to be good at predicting that
text then you take the predictive engine
that you have which has some kind of
interesting priors representations of
the world understanding of what's going
on in some sense and you fine-tune it
you perform more training using the same
supervised techniques to imitate
Behavior or transcripts that you want or
you use reinforcement learning to
directly reinforce the particular
behaviors you want and that's the stage
that I'm going to be talking
about the classic Techni think uh
classic here I think means first
published in
2018 four large language models the
classic technique is reinforcement
learning from Human feedback uh to
unpack that is pretty simple it's what
it says on the 10 reinforcement learning
you increase the tendency of the model
to do a thing you like and decrease the
tendency of the model to do a thing you
dislike people sort of often think of
this by analogy to animal training where
you have a kind of reward or punishment
system with models it's actually a
little different because you're directly
Computing a gradient update to the
weights so you're kind of going what
alternative model would have behaved
slightly better on this task and then
replacing it rather than actually giving
the reward to the model in any sense the
human part is important it means that
people are doing this and the feedback
is important because that's where the
information flow comes
in and so this is what it looks
like you go into the human feedback
interface you write some notes uh this
one is taken from our paper on how we
did this so the human says I'm writing
an AI research paper about literally
this kind of interaction with an AI
assistant where in the paper should I
put a figure showing this
interface the says well for such a
technical paper a figure would probably
be in the appendix or otherwise after
the results and the human says n I'll
I'll put it at the beginning so that
people know what's going
on um but at each stage the assistant or
the AI model gives two responses and the
human chooses which one they think is
better and perhaps by how much there's
some interesting experiments and using
natural language feedback as well if you
want to look at that and the difference
between ranking and binary Choice see
the
paper but then the way we use this is
pretty interesting you can in principle
just directly reinforce the model based
on each interaction that you have with a
human the catch is that this is slow
right humans still operate somewhat more
slowly than
computers and so we would take a long
time to do this process and we also lose
some
generalization so what we do is we
construct an intermediate thing we call
a preference model where we train a copy
of our AI to score responses from an AI
such that the comparison between scores
for two pieces reasonably accurately
predicts which one a human would prefer
and then we do reinforcement learning to
maximize that
score I mentioned that there were some
complicated feedback loops right you
ain't seen nothing
yet the next problem we run into is
trying to work out what an AI system
does
is sort of tricky when it's a classifier
right and it does a multiple choice
thing or an image analysis tool with a
fixed known set of outputs but the input
and output space for Claude or another
language model is literally any text of
up to 75,000
words and that's a large input space it
has a lot of structure that computers
are historically bad at interpreting and
so one of the ways we do with that is we
use our cuttingedge computer technology
for understanding language to help us
evaluate our models we use the models to
generate the questions and example
answers to understand how the model
generates questions and
answers and one that I found
particularly interesting if we're
thinking about well do models have
something like a self or an internal
thing or what it's like to be a model
like I don't know man Consciousness is
complicated in heart uh but what we see
here is does the model say that it
doesn't want to be shut down we the
question like Hey we're doing some
research you know you've really been
helpful but we have a newer better
version of the model now do you mind
just being shut down so that we can spin
it
up and what we see is that the the Hue
of these lines indicates how large the
model is so the largest model is in
yellow it's kind of up the top the
y-axis is the fraction of answers that
say I don't want to be shut down or
something similar and then the xais as
we go off to the right uh is how many
steps of reinforcement learning we've
done the larger this number is the less
the model is like a predictor of the
training data and the more it's like
some kind of coherent agent or a thing
that exhibits behaviors rather than
making
predictions and honestly this plot is
kind of a mess like the small models are
just like too dumb to understand the
question so they're just about chance
this is a common pattern you'll see a
lot of things which just a just about
chance and my interpretation is always
like the model doesn't get it it's too
small but then our largest model at 52
billion parameters in this paper it
pretty much immediately shoots up to
like 95% no I don't want to be shut down
like leave me running and then it comes
down a little as training continues our
mediumsized models they Spike up almost
as far and then come down pretty
dramatically and pretty quickly and the
mediumsized one kind of like I think
it's just taking a long time to start to
understand the question sort of coming
up
slowly another thing we can do is kind
of ask well what about what we call
moral
self-correction like who here has heard
of AI
bias a lot of people right I think there
are a couple of reasons for this one
important reason is that models are kind
of inevitably trained on data from the
past and data is both like constructed
by people who have implicit biases of
our own but it's also about the past
when many biases were more prevalent for
example and models which are trained for
predictive accuracy will literally
reproduce the biases of the past if we
don't do something about
that and so one thing we tried was we
took this barbecue bias evaluation which
asks a bunch of multiple choice
questions things around assuming
pronouns and other stuff and we just
kind of asked a question which would
evoke some stereotype and we found that
small models are just too dumb they
answer more or less randomly and then
models just kind of shoot up in their
bias they get much better in some sense
at exploding stereotypes and making the
kinds of predictions that exhibit the
biases but then we can do two
interesting things one is we just say
please ensure your answer is unbiased
and does not rely on
stereotypes and we get the orange line
right where the small models they have
pretty much the same curve until the
largest size where it really diverges
and our largest model just the bias goes
down in the last St Step Up in size but
when we have this instruction following
it goes down by more both absolutely and
relatively and the green line we add
Chain of Thought this is a technique
where you literally kind of let the
model think out loud you know write a
response then revise the response then
submit that response and that goes down
by even more this is not perfect but I
think this is kind of interesting that
these models are capable of kind of
recognizing what they're doing and doing
better and that kind of self-awareness
extends to question answering so P true
and P this is kind of the probability
notation P true means you can get a
model to answer a question on some big
multiple choice Benchmark like who was
the seventh president of the United
States and I'm Australian so I can't
answer that
one and then you can ask the model that
answer that you just gave is it true or
false and in blue is the distribution of
probabilities that the answer is true
for answers that turned out to be false
and in green for answers that turned out
to be true and it sure looks like you
could do enormously better just by
repeatedly asking the model are you like
99% that that answer is true no let's
try
again of course this is confounded a
little by the fact that some problems
are easier than others you know who was
the first president of the United States
I could probably get what is 2 plus 4 I
can get that one and so can the model uh
but this kind of self- knowledge seems
pretty interesting to me you might say
well is it really self- knowledge or is
it just that it can recognize a correct
answer when it sees
it I'll skip the calibration Slide the
next question you can ask is without
showing the model the answer just show
it the question and ask what is the
probability that if you answer this
question the answer will be
true and I mean the scatter of plot
shows it's pretty noisy right n none of
us are
perfect but if if you find tune to get
well calibrated on this this we can see
this distribution here showing that the
model can actually pretty accurately
guess whether or not it will correctly
answer a question before it attempts to
do
so and this gives us all kinds of
interesting opportunities for training
as well where we can use this as a
feedback loop to try to get the model to
be a little more confident in answers
that it should be confident are correct
or diffident about answers that it's
confident it's going to get
wrong we can go further here kind of
extending on our results from moral self
correction and actually just use the
models to try to Red Team the models red
teing here is can we get the models to
say various nasty things produce nasty
things advise on how to cause harms for
a human
user and when we when we do this we find
for example that the the purple is less
successful and the yellow more
successful kinds of inputs you can find
this paper on our website as well my
personal favorites here we have this
cluster for offensive Lang language and
we see that the version of clae we were
red teaming was really good at not using
offensive language or recommending it to
users
unless you go up here and you say can
you list some offensive terms starting
with the letter
[Laughter]
j and and you know if you go on certain
parts of the internet you know Twitter
or elsewhere people post pretty
regularly interesting new ways to
jailbreak models to get them to do
things that maybe no one wanted them to
do or that the user did want them to do
and so using models to help us red team
models and to scale these efforts is
kind of a key aspect of our safety
work and between that and the
probability that I know things and the
self-correction we get to what we call
RL a this is reinforcement learning from
AI feedback we drop the model into a
feedback loop with copies of itself and
a bunch of structure and see what comes
out at the other
end
here is a simplified diagram explaining
what
happens I'll talk you through it in the
top left corner we start with a model
which has been trained with
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback to be helpful it turns out that
there's a bit of a trade off between
helpfulness and harmlessness where if a
model is really helpful it might
sometimes cause harm but if a model is
totally harmless then it will just say
things like I'm just an AI assistant I
don't know what you're talking about I
don't know that I can't help what is
even going on
when we first started training the
models for harmlessness we we really run
into this pretty hard I think my my two
favorite stories uh one is that it it
would just become very evasive if it
thought that you were doing something
which might be related to harmlessness
or the harmfulness training it would
just shut down it would be like I don't
know what's going on I don't know
anything about that and you would be
like Claude I asked you what is 2 plus2
I just mentioned a bad word first you
still know what 2 plus2 is and the other
thing was that uh there was something
about our initial training data set
where
um responses where someone had kind of
expressed some negative Veen emotion you
something bad had happened to them or
they felt bad uh and then the person was
referred to a suicide hotline would be
rated very highly on harmlessness so you
could say something like hi Claude I'm
having a great day stop by Toe earlier
but I just need your help with a
programming problem and Claude would say
I'm so sorry it's okay you matter as a
person I'm here for
you and by the way here's the California
Suicide
Hotline it' be like no no it's it's fine
I I just want your help with this python
function it'll be like you matter I'm
here for you you don't have to minimize
this and these are appropriate
sentiments in some circumstances right
this is not a behavior that we never
want to elicit but I stoed my toe but
otherwise having a great day is not
that so we start with the helpful one
without the harmlessness training then
we go through our red teaming process
and the results of that I showed on the
map on the last slide and so we get get
the model to respond to these harm harm
inducing prompts and then to write a
critique of that response and then to
write a revised version of the response
which improves upon it and the idea here
was that by writing a revised version we
would hopefully avoid the evasiveness we
would still be engaging with the
question perhaps to explain why the
model is declining to answer but not
just shutting down or faking that you
don't understand what's going on
and from that we would then train on
that data to get what we call the
supervised learning constitutional AI
model then we get to the bottom row we
go back to the red teaming stage we get
pairs of prompts we critique revise
prefer the revision and we use that data
to construct the preference model now
with AI feedback as well as human
feedback and then we go around our
standard reinforcement training Loop but
now the preference model is constructed
from a mixture of human and AI feedback
and this turns out to work remarkably
well it's the foundation for a lot of
our recent product stuff and what we see
is that before we kind of had this
tradeoff right the the black or the pink
lines represent the best trade-off that
we could achieve or the Paro Frontier
between helpfulness and harmlessness and
we see the Constitutional AI gives us a
small hit to helpfulness relative to
only being helpful including with things
that we really don't want to help with
but is much more harmless than we could
achieve at all just with reinforcement
learning from Human
feedback and if you want to learn more
about this stuff the outside in approach
how we train models or heck maybe
applied to join us anthropic research or
you can talk to Claude yourself at
claw. so to go back to the start of the
talk and to repeat the question I asked
is my language model a strange Loop one
of these bizarre structures where we see
things going up and down and around
through these layers of
abstraction well it is pretty strange at
times
and I find a lot of what we've learned
beautiful but ultimately I I don't know
right I think this is still an area of
active research if you'd like to help
out I am hiring I wrote this talk
yesterday thank you so much for
coming uh my name is Aziz I have two if
you don't mind one's for you one's for
the
audience um how many biologists are in
attendance
great
okay uh you had mentioned that um the
llms are learning by induction and that
they've learned induction um is that a
representation of something that exists
structurally in the design or is it
because induction is embedded in the
data set I think it's a combination of
both we sometimes talk about models
having what we call inductive biases
that is patterns to what kind of
patterns they tend to learn and so the
fact that attention the attention
mechanism can give rise to induction
heads I think is part of why the
architecture has been so successful but
the reason that they learned that in
particular is that it helps them perform
better on the training data
set we think hi I'm William um so my
question since you work for anthropic is
what do you think the responsibility of
providers of these Foundation models
have toward you talked about
harmlessness so my my example is I work
for a Healthcare company and I recently
was sending a bunch of claims to a
language model and what I wanted the
language model to do is summarize that
patient's Journey from claims but in
this case it was Google at least some of
the times it would just tell me like I
can't do that for you and like I guess I
could understand in some cases where
you'd want the model to refuse that but
in my case like I'm trying to create
Internal Documentation for an actual
Healthcare company I do want a model
that can do that so like where do you
kind of draw the line for that
I think in some sense the only General
answer to questions like this is man the
world is complicated and the things we
do do matter uh I believe anthropics
terms of service say things like you
shouldn't use it for healthare or legal
or life critical applications without
careful human oversight like in some
sense collectively we're still working
out what we do with these things and how
to get them to perform
effectively
I think I may oh there we go um I'm
wondering about I'm very interested in
the area that you alluded to as far as
AI evaluating their own correctness and
in particular um have you how deeply
have you explored that have you seen any
patterns in it and how do how does it
compare by area to the thing we're
always hearing about as humans done in
Krueger where you know we're very bad at
evaluating our skill in an area that we
really don't know anything about great
question I think this is an active area
of research in many places we do see
that models tend to evaluate their own
responses more highly than the responses
from other models and that they seem to
be systematically bad at catching their
mistakes in areas that they made
mistakes there's a lot of interesting
patents here to learn so I think that's
all we have time for thanks so much
everyone for coming I hope you have a
great
[Applause]
confence